in the next few sessions we will cover
topics related to bioinformatics
analysis of rna-seq data transcriptomics
is the central component with an
increasing level of complexity
throughout the lessons the sessions are
meant to provide you with an additional
layer of information and answer any
questions that you may have
the bytes and molecules course provides
an overview of important research topics
and applications of bioinformatics for a
novice the main transcriptomics module
will provide you with in-depth materials
on specific challenges for rna-seq data
analysis both in small data sets and
large-scale studies the theoretical
training will be supplemented by
exercises using the t by info analysis
platform for processing assignments and
optional coding exercises which can be
completed in r or python on your
computer or using our online coding
environment
in addition you will find a range of
project examples to see how such
techniques are used in oncology
immunology infectious diseases and
agriculture
today we will start with an introduction
what is rna expression
how can it be measured and what are some
of the technical steps to get started
with next generation sequencing data
analysis for gene expression
quantification
the process of rna transcription is key
to determine the cellular phenotype it
kicks off with the rna polymerase adding
complementary nucleotides to a dna
template strands
as a result of modifications at all of
these steps the cell phenotype is
determined resulting in over 200
different types of cells in the human
body these technologies developed over
time becoming more and more
sophisticated as a result of automation
refinement of the technology and a
greater understanding of the underlying
biology today the cost to sequence a
full genome is already less than a
thousand dollars and there's an ever
increasing number of genomic
transcriptomic proteomic and metagenomic
datasets available for the public to use
that describes subcellular processes
with highly detailed digital datums
first rna that was extracted from cells
is converted to cdna that is then
sheared and placed in a flow cell inside
the flow cell the cdna fragments are
amplified using bridge pcr amplification
and the flow cell is inserted into the
sequencer this machine uses image
analysis to capture each letter in the
flow cell by analyzing visual patterns
and converting them to a sequence of
letters these letters are the digital
equivalent of a short fragment of rna
also called a read now that the reads
are aligned we can visually see them
including their abundance here seen on
top in gray and the actual reads
represented in red and blue rectangles
underneath each region following the
annotation in the gtf file needs to be
assigned with a number
genes can be of different lengths and
the number of reads is not always the
same but we will try to simplify the
process first to give you a clear sense
of read count
so each region contains a certain number
of reads simply counting their number
equals the raw read count assigned to
each genomic element
to practice these steps you can review
additional demo pipelines and play
around with various combinations of
methods
you will notice the specific method
links
input and output file formats as well as
the final results in the download
section
to learn about these processing steps we
prepared a collection of sample files
that you can practice with
in the course
lessons one through five are dedicated
to processing and preparation of data
for
analysis
in addition you will find several
projects that you will find referenced
in the portal to expand your
understanding of how such methods are
used in the context of specific project
examples